Deadpool 2 was bigger louder and packed
with even more insanity than the
original Deadpool still for us bombastic
as a movie was there were a surprising
number of subtle references and obscure
characters adapted for the big screen
from a lesson on box office history to
quick nods to comic-book continuity here
are small details you missed in Deadpool
sir
our rated domination in Deadpool to the
Merc with a mouth acknowledges a success
of Deadpool by telling the audiences
about the box office history of some of
the highest-grossing r-rated movies that
lesson wouldn't be complete without
mentioning the highest-grossing r-rated
movie in u.s. box office history The
Passion of the Christ the film earned an
astonishing domestic gross of over 370
million dollars while Mel Gibson's
biblical epic might never get toppled
from his throne in terms of how much it
made in America it's a different story
internationally their poor managed to
earn a staggering 783 million dollars
worldwide making the violent superhero
romp the highest-grossing r-rated
international film of all time not bad
for a character that once got pizza by
Squirrel Girl prior straits x-men
continuity is generally a confusing mess
spread through dozens of comic series as
well as decades of retcons and unusual
complicated familial revelations even
within that knot of continuity there's
arguably no character with a more
complicated family history than cable as
the son of Scott Summers and the clone
of Jean Grey named Madeleine prior the
Fanueil Summers has been to the Future
was infected with a techno-organic virus
by a powerful supervillain and even fled
through time protecting a little girl
that looks suspiciously like his own
mother in shorts he's pretty complicated
while Deadpool too stays away from too
many plates and easter eggs involving
Josh Brolin's cable there are quick
references to his comic book roots
immediately after most of the newly
formed x-force parachutes into a
suburban neighborhood and meet their
untimely demise 'as an ice-cream truck
can be seen with a logo reading Pryor's
treats referring to cables biological
mother mother limb prior House of M
their paws no stranger to twisted
timelines himself as his dialog in both
the Deadpool and Deadpool 2 would
suggest words of school talk to the
professor
McAvoy or Stewart please diamond
music for metatextual knowledge of
Professor Xavier different actors to his
blasts a relationship of time-travel the
Merc with a mouth seems to take it all
in stride still maybe he should have
been a little more worried about the
banners that hung inside the Essex House
that read em day is coming longtime
comic readers might remember the M day
is the in the universe turn / when
Scarlet Witch erases a mutant genome in
House of M M day goes down in Marvel
history as a dark time for mutants since
the resulting wife of the mutant race
sticks around for years the mutant
population in the Marvel Universe
actually drops from tens of thousands
all the way to just a couple hundred for
years the mutant population slowly
dwindled right until a very important
mutant baby is born that mutant Hope
Summers cable's daughter
no wonder cables so grumpy in the movie
if he's from such a grim future
Irene Merryweather during Russell
Collins first fiery appearance of
Deadpool - even the on-screen reporter
is a supporting character who appeared
in the comic series cable and Deadpool
like a movie counterpart Irene Mary
where there is a reporter but the comics
version of the character goes on a much
wilder series of adventures and a quick
movie appearance would suggest she's
been the chronicler of cables adventures
a writer for The Daily Bugle an object
of Deadpool's romantic affections and
the chief of staff on an entire island
states that's a heck of a resume x-men
fan while movie Deadpool could pretend
to be too cool for Xavier school comic
book Deadpool is a pretty big x-men fan
since Deadpool breaks the fourth wall
more often than the wrecking crew breaks
actual walls this manifests and him
referencing specific issue numbers when
he gets excited in temple - when
juggernaut appears the Merc with a mouth
tells him how big a fan he is and named
Sri juggernaut centric comic book issues
and cannae x-men issue 183 x-men and
limited issue 12 and Thor issue 411
beyond just featuring the juggernauts
all three issues have a thematic
connection as well juggernaut taking
down increasingly powerful enemies in
uncanny x-men issue 183 juggernaut
brings an entire building down on
Colossus and a bar fight in Thor issue
411 juggernaut fights and completely
defeats Thor the God of Thunder
finally in x-men unlimited issue 12
juggernaut fights a cosmic entity that
controls his power cyttorak
and defeats him too
if Deadpool's been reading these comics
is no wonder he's such a fan of Cain
Marko and when Deadpool says quote it
has always been a dream of mine to see
myself reflected in your helmet as you
charge me with murderous intent well
that's actually happened on the cover of
his own book on Deadpool issue two
dreams really do come true
beyond the comic-book reference has a
very good reason for Deadpool to get
excited about fighting the juggernauts
much like having a tragic origin or
joining the Avengers fighting the
insufferable force of the juggernauts is
basically a rite of passage in the
Marvel Universe Colossus did it Thor did
it even spider-man has done it
welcome to the big leagues Wade Wilson
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're loved today
[Music]